all right 6 38 the hustle and bustle of
the holiday season is over the cookies
have been eaten the eggnog has been
drunk for the most part yeah for the
most part you're probably stuffed like
me and it's time to talk about Fitness
resolutions so we have a few short
simple workouts that maybe you can try
at home with Candace Charles who's live
up in the Northwest Valley at EOS
Fitness to help us all get started on
our New Year's fitness goals Candace
good morning
good morning to you too good morning
folks I know
daunting but it really doesn't have to
be the first step is really getting
started the second step be realistic
folks in keeping it simple I have here
with Miracle Holly he tells me in the
beginning of the year you start to see a
lot of people come in and then it starts
to taper off but you know the last
couple years that's changed what is some
of the reasons people don't come back
you know I don't think they give
themselves a goal that's attainable and
also I don't think they set time aside
for themselves to be selfish right you
got to be selfish plan ahead if you
don't plan ahead you it's easy to say
I'll do it tomorrow right so we don't
want to plan ahead we want to put a
schedule on there just like work put in
your schedule and make it and make it
happen all right and one of the things
that could be on the schedule is doing
this what is this exactly so right now
you got to step up just like you do
aerobics what we're going to do is we're
going to have you step over we're going
to have you do a little squat kind of a
curtsy squat okay and then you're gonna
hold a kettlebell so we're gonna work
some of your legs some of your core
everything's about core so we're gonna
do that right now with Denise all right
Denise thank you so much for joining us
she is the train here yes okay tell me
how this work I'm hand over my mic to
her alrighty you are going to you I'm
holding the mic you are going to hold
the Kettlebell up okay you are going to
cross over behind you do a little Squat
and back and forth all right and this
makes your butt rounder rounder now to
modify that at home if you do not have a
step what you do is just do it on the
floor okay you can just it's a curtsy
right
all right sounds good thank you so much
niece thank you Eric seem simple enough
you guys can do some of these at home
we've done a few different things the
ropes we've done a little bit of uh
using the Rope here to kind of get your
core hair nice as well we've done some I
think it's called V tracks t-tracks
maybe TRX there you go it does some of
those as well you can catch some of
those on our website we'll definitely
try to put those on our website for you
guys so you can do them as well again
cut out maybe some of that food and use
it down here at the gym it's like 9.99
to get started if you want to give with
the trainer like the niece here 30 to 70
bucks of course you guys cover all the
details on our website newsnow.com for
now live from eels off of Rome I'm
Candace Charles eight news now again
thank you John was talking earlier how
do I make my booty more rounded I know
I've been working on that for years I've
been trying to train and train and train
and now I know the exercise
Squad it's a Christmas Squad I think in
Canada